Bruce starts off this hour in Seattle
Washington hi Bruce welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show
I'm mr. Ramsey thanks for taking my call
sure what's up well so the question I
have is you've you've talked about
paying down debt and the snowball method
and every time you talk you say hey hey
get current pay your minimums and start
the snowball well my question is if you
don't care about that in the future and
you don't want to use credit cards or
your credit score at all why not take
all available income and pay off your
smallest debt and let things default
right I mean you'll get to when you get
to them and you'll just settle if you
can and you're attacking the snowball
faster by taking all available income
and attacking the debt specifically
because my daddy would whip me in the
woodshed if I didn't keep my word and I
was able to so this is more of a
morality issue and not a practical issue
this is a stewardship issue and not
practical it's it is a morality issue to
keep your word when you're able to yes
and it is practical always to do that as
well because there's a high correlation
of people that have in between extreme
levels of integrity and the ability to
build wealth and so trying to scam the
system generally does not cause people
to build wealth and so you know you gave
your word if you're able to keep your
word you pay it now I've been in
situations where I wasn't able to
because I was so stupid I left myself
drowning and couldn't breathe and you
can't do you can't do what you said you
were gonna do you're getting a traffic
jam and you can't be on time for a
meeting that you set the time on that's
nice breaking your word you know but you
it was beyond your control you didn't
have what he couldn't left earlier but I
mean you know the whole thing is that so
yeah yeah the other thing from a
practical standpoint is this stuff will
catch up with you I mean there you're
just setting out you know there's other
things that people are gonna look at
your credit bureau report for later and
when it appears that you've purposefully
gone into default in order to create a
deal or as an act of irresponsibility
that stuff's gonna catch up with you I
don't believe in struggle
and striving to build your credit bureau
report or to build your credit score I
also don't believe in just intentionally
destroying it either so that that's the
basis for that you can live your life
however you want Bruce but you called me
and so I'll give you what I think and
that's what I do here so living in your
shoes what I do I pay my bills and I get
out of debt as fast as I could